all-star sunday in the city of atlanta  where the best in the game will gather  taco bell  skills challenge begins the competitions  here on all-star  sunday  mountain dew three-point contest  championship this is a  one-man race d-wade here we go  [Music]  oh  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh  [Music]  now it's time for the 70th nba all-star  game it's team lebron going  against team durant  tatum sets it up for zion williamson  three-pointer for yellowstone  lebron gets down court  [Applause]  [Music]  anything you can do i can do better mr  lillard  see team lebron dominating team durant  [Music]  lillard for three yes game time baby  two on one finished by donovan mitchell  and irving on the drive and he stops  [Music]  lebron with the victory